[音楽]
地味社長様友達になってくださいぽんちゃ
何言ってんだよ
おれたちともだち大労組ず弾みそうです
マックナゲット中コピー仕掛ける67戸
戦後このマックナゲットホットなんで準備
しました3番8860円でございます何で
バックだけとせんかったかと言いますと
今から衝撃なこと言いますねマック
ナゲットって
上種類しか存在しないらしいんですよ
やれってなかっただからナゲットで
いろんな形があるなっていう印象があった
んですけどもなんかマックナゲット4つ
しか存在しないらしいんですよ形がネット
とかいろんな情報をみて調べてきましたね
ちょっと紹介させて下さい栄養素でこちら
になりますデルマナカクリスタルがたと
いうか菱形っぽいやつですねデルっていう
のがありますねもう一個このブート都道府
県にあるような形ですねただボール基本的
な丸いやつですこのナゲットなんか見た
感じがありますそしてもう一個ポーン
ちょっと死確定っぽい形ですねこれ皆さん
知ってましたってこれ今だに信じてないん
ですけどベルグーッとぽんぽよマック
ナゲットはこのよう処理だけらしいんです
よどうやらマジでスクではタクシー思い
ましたそんなことあっていいのか今まで
たくさん食べてきたバッグで get4
種類あって本当なのかさすがに例外がある
のではないかということで今回の動画では
マックナゲット先行サンプルに本当に4
種類だけなのかどうかひょっとしたら例外
が出てくるかもしれません例会出てきた俺
名前付きますからね勝手に市西五所店発見
されず名前付きますからねそもそも本当に
ベルループボールゾーンの用水だけなのか
そして健康もあるんだから確率も出したい
なぁと思ってます4種類といってもこれが
全部20コパ25パン25番25バーたい
ということあるのかなとどれかが0だから
ちゃんとレートは借りたいじゃないですか
そしたらまたマック何とも食べ方も楽しく
なるんじゃないかということで今回は私が
身を持ってそもそも本当に分布ゴール本
だけなのか4 b と呼ばせて下さい
そもそも4 b だけなのかそして4つ
だけだとしたら確率はどうなっているのが
出荷りとチェストしていきたいと思います
よ行こうか
軽い軽い
あの事前にちゃんと連絡してマクドナルド
さんで準備していましたので中お店の迷惑
にかかるようななんか無理やり先行とか
やってないんですきちんとお店にご迷惑が
かからないように予約して注文させて
いただきました鎧のが戦後 p 止まると
弱とマスターのたくさん付いてくるんです
けど初めて箱で渡されました初めてこれで
渡されたすごいずうずう下校こんな渡さ
れればあるかねこんな渡され方ないけど
これぐらいの量ず頼んだのでやるからな
しっかり継承していきましょうはいでとっ
て検証していくかというとこうが出るを
グーッと学校を全部開封してってここに
どんどん並べていきたいとおもいますそれ
で千石撫子ピースと食べ猛暑せいか審議
ですけどこれなんだブーブーでしょ
これはそれにこれは実にボールでしょなん
となくなんとなくわかるぜないがここが
[ __ ]ってなっているのがブートっぽい
ってなんかずーっとが多い気がするのは
菱形っぽいですねこれが多分ベルが暗く
午後撮ってみたんですけど結構バランスっ
て言って言わせればホン4この辺ほなので
バク現在とママ
では早速仕分け作業をやっていきたいと
おもいますはい
ん
ペーパーボウルとか全然わからんっていい
んですかこれはが出ていあこれと壁ですね
なんかをとってみたいな部分のある床
レベルです
全然違うブートですちょっと待ってまず6
水を[ __ ]といい部分あれだったらこれが
タブーとこれはおそらくぼーん
パー2
パーンこのやボンバー
ブーツ pro シートカバーブーンっ
プロキシ型っぽいですねこれぺんぺん
ホッケこんな感じでやっていきましょう
山路ボーンとブートの違いがわからんだ
これファン等バーっトーン
道
同
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇこれえげつない事してんな
これこれ今気づいたけどヤバイことしてん
なぁ
バーンっ
てわーブートとコーンの見分けがまず
難しいです俺じゃないと分からないプー
ンっ
てくるっ子
web
心
なんとなく100個ほど多分あったと思い
ますすごいねマジで形が一緒ですはいこそ
レベルゾーンでベルガモほらもう
ダイヤモンド方なんで全部ブートもうね
なんかそのて畑みたいな形かなと思ったら
結構見分けやすくなっていますかボールは
そのままで染まるければボールでで本は
ちょっと四角形なんですけども雑感横が来
いってし今回は出たら本ですさすがに先行
レバー音が入っ9階れ犠打が出てきても
おかしくないと思うけどプレスマンと混ぜ
て様子と言うしかないですから下手なマジ
でわかったよ7ずに並べていきたいと
おもいます
あべしーじゃん皆さん審議が出ましたみな
さんこれどう思いますこの方っ
ベレにしては肘肩ではないクリスターでは
ないブートにしてばあまりに短いボーンに
しては仕掛けじゃないボールではない
仕掛けですよひし形にしてはちょっと指次
にこれらべるの非対称型って感じですから
これ goot ことで事態やのここで
パウダーを殴ってんだろうなこれ誰にも
伝わらないなこれ今だけ仕分けすると僕は
わかるんですけどこれちょっと今までない
形で新酒ですこれベルにしたら絶対形
おかしいどれにも当てはまらないと思い
ますデータぞきみのちょっと解明名前
突き出しください5種類味です黄色い決め
ました
この名前はどう撮っ goes めぐりー
さーこれが選手です後処理坊主にくいです
を覚えておいてください
[音楽]
ブーブーています
息子のぼブーブー
ボーボー錦濤は江連坊
ブーツ
[音楽]
待ったきますた煮込みきましたこれも
たぶん坊主めくりです終わりますかね
ヴェルニ者左右対称じゃないんですよ
[音楽]
はいちょっと並べて徒歩でブーツが
いっぱいになってしまいました置き場所が
フェルです
もうほんとに
クリスタル方っていうかそういうのが
いっぱいありますルートのブーツのことだ
よってもすごくな全部ちゃんとねーなーが
ブーツの形になってるんですよなグッズ
みたいな形にボールです丸いだけです本
ブーツとの見分けがちょっと難しいんです
けど基本な長方形というかなんだろう南下
したは四角形で上が丸くなってればもう
それはボーンからっていくんで全部同じ形
だと思いますブーツ100になったんです
けど置く場所がないので行ったいこと全部
dqn で新しく乾燥していきます
半数を終わりました
正直楽しくないしちょっと中が報告で数
数えていきましょうかエネが125個
ルートが112戸ボールが120個
ボーガー130よポーン多いぞ妹も結構
那覇でボーンが多いですまた500腕ので
ちょっとダンスあると思うんですけどもう
ちょっと本若干多いわからなくなってき
ましたねちょっとを最後で図っていきたい
とおもいますじゃあ
[音楽]
me
というわけで結構ベレーもボールの妨害も
含ませてきたので100個舌ちょっとイケ
てるの時はソープスペースを確保してから
残りをやっていきたいとおもいます
うわぁしたべたに来ましたポーズべ栗です
ええっ罵倒
またポーズめくりでございます増えてき
たらここに入って
チャンドラーんブーバー boo
ana
ああああああ
with ん
true
売ってってい
てるん
wh
me
[音楽]
hype 指で集計結果かけました8分
開いていただきます松根レット仙骨の
ベル
255個ぶー
248展望
そして坊主
ロック以上の結果になります
そっかなるほどね多分ですけど平均的に出
ますベルが25.5ばブーツが23.6
パワーボール20.8本2215点5思っ
たらグーッとボールはほぼこそだと分ね
あの多分ですけども全部同じくらいの確率
で出ることが分かりました
ファイプロ誰かを買って検証しないとこの
4種類が平均的に入ってるって分から
なかったので私は今回やってよかったなと
思いました
[音楽]
戦後は人でジャムりあ
誰が
ポリ
[音楽]
paddy
el立ったかちょ